[Musik]
phoenix persönlich es ist der ort der
hoffnung der hoffnung auf eine rückkehr
zu unserem normalen alltäglichen leben
das impfzentrum hier in bonn
ja wann werden wir in dieses normale
leben zurückkehren können wird es die
impfung seien die uns dahin zurückführt
größe sehr herzlich professor henrik
strikt so einen guten tag für tag den
strick ist dass der ausweg aus dieser
pandemie
nun ich denke dass ein impfstoff ein
wichtiger baustein sein wird um uns aus
dieser pandemie zu führen aber wir
dürfen uns nicht alleine auf den
impfstoff verlassen wir wissen ja noch
nicht mal ob der impfstoff vor einer
infektion schützt oder nur vor einer
schweren erkrankung so dass wir mit den
anderen maßnahmen auch weiterhin im
moment die infektionszahlen runter
halten müssen wir alle aber hoffen doch
so sehr auf die impfung und wir sind
doch alle auch sehr überrascht wie
schnell das gegangen ist ich weiß dass
sie in einer der letzten sendungen die
wir live miteinander machen konnten also
persönlich miteinander sprechen konnten
im märz über die impfung gesprochen
haben und haben sie gesagt na ja also
die impfung da weiß ich nur gar nicht
wenn die kommen kann
das wird noch eine ganze zeit dauern und
wir müssen möglicherweise viele andere
möglichkeiten nutzen das ist jetzt viel
schneller gegangen
also das war eine erfolgsgeschichte ist
kann man gar nicht anders sagen wir es
gibt ja eine unzählige viren und erreger
wo wir schon seit jahrzehnten an
impfstoffen forschen und versuchen
impfstoffe zu entwickeln und wir können
das gar nicht vorhersagen ob im
impfstoff funktionieren wird oder nicht
und gerade der rna im stoff da die
meisten experten eigentlich gesagt dass
es gar nicht so sicher ob er überhaupt
was bringt darum wurde von denen ja auch
nicht so viel impfstoff am anfang
gekauft dass der jetzt gerade so einen
guten erfolg gebracht hat damit haben
viele nicht gerechnet
sie haben ja sehr lange jahre und auch
immer noch geforscht nach einem
impfstoff gegen aids in der
aids-forschung ist man da nicht wirklich
sehr viel weiter gekommen man kann das
mit medikamenten
sehr gut behandeln das haben sie auch
immer wieder dargestellt aber mit dem
impfstoff das ist eines der träume die
sie haben oder eine der träume die sie
haben in ihrem leben diesen impfstoff zu
entwickeln
warum ist der unterschied da so groß ist
dass ein viel sich schnell entwickelnder
virus oder wie kommt es also wir hatten
im hiv bereich immer die erfahrung
gemacht dass wenn wir einen impfstoff
entwickelt haben und denen dann getestet
haben dass die ergebnisse in dieser
phase 3 die wir ja jetzt für den corona
im stoff gerade erst beendet haben immer
komplett überraschend fahren manchmal
hat der impfstoff ein bisschen ein
signal gezeigt manchmal war er sogar
schlechter weil man den impfstoff
verwendet hat also diese phase 3 war
immer eine überraschung
im moment läuft gerade ein impfstoff
wieder in der phase 3 und wir können
dieses jahr wieder hoffen im juli/august
dass er dort die ersten ergebnisse sehen
werden und vielleicht hat er ja auch
wieder ein signal ein positives signal
was ich damit sagen will wir können das
überhaupt nicht vorhersagen ob es
funktioniert und es kann sein dass der
nächste impfstoff und vielleicht auch
durch die forschung jetzt ein corona ein
neuer impfstoff auf erneuerbare es
funktionieren könnte aber kann das nicht
umgekehrt auch heißen die ja ich habe
gerade gesagt setzen alle hoffnungen auf
diese impfstoffe im augenblick wir
wollen das alte leben ja möglichst
schnell wieder zurück haben dass der
impfstoff dann doch sich irgendwann
herausstellt als ein impfstoff der zwar
vielleicht die krankheit nicht so massiv
ausbrechen lässt aber den mut nicht
wirklich verhindert dass wir
zurückkehren können das ist natürlich
etwas was passieren kann dass dieser
impfstoff eben nicht vor der infektion
schützt sondern nur vor einem schweren
verlauf und ich habe am anfang der
pandemie bereits schon gesagt dass wir
anfangen müssen zu lernen mit dem virus
zu leben das ist keine plattitüde das
ist keine floskel die ich das sage wenn
ich das sage sondern wenn man das
verinnerlicht dass dieses virus
wahrscheinlich heimisch wird dass wir es
nicht erzielen können
dass es uns unser leben lang
wahrscheinlich begleiten wird dann ist
das ein ganz anderer umgang mit dem
virus dann sind die infektionszahlen gar
nicht mehr so zentral sondern viel
wichtiger ist die frage werden die
menschen krank und kranke menschen das
ist das was einem als arzt interessiert
und was man verhindern will
trotzdem wird immer wieder gesagt das
sind neuartige impfstoffe die jetzt
großartige ergebnisse in den ersten
zahlen belegen aber es gibt in der
bevölkerung viel unsicherheit das ist so
schnell gegangen sagte einer dann
misstrauisch dem der andere sagte er das
sind neuartige impfstoffe da weiß man ja
noch gar nicht was da am ende passiert
nach ein paar jahren möglicherweise kann
man da beruhigen oder muss man sagen das
risiko ist da also ich kann erst mal
diese skepsis verstehen weil der
klebstoffe entwicklung ist wahnsinnig
schnell gewesen und natürlich auch etwas
gewesen was ja viele erstmal nicht so
gedacht haben dass es so schnell gut
funktionieren würde
aber im grunde wenn man sich vorstellt
dass das virus genau die gleiche rna
einbringt also wenn man sich infiziert
bringt man genau die gleiche ehre erna
in den körper ein
nur jetzt bei diesem impfstoff ist es
ein kleiner bestandteil beim anderen ist
es ein ganz großer bestandteil und je
nachdem ob infektionen oder impfstoff
würde man den gleichen bestandteil
abkriegen so ist dieser kleine schnipsel
viel sicherer wahrscheinlich als ein
ganzes virus trotzdem ist diese
entwicklung sehr sehr schnell vor sich
gegangen die ihr alle sind so ein
bisschen unsicher selbst diejenigen die
in den ärztlichen medizinischen
bereichen arbeiten wie kommt das ist
dass sie haben immer wieder vor der
angst gewarnt diese teilweise schlimmer
als der virus selber ist das zu viel
angst die wir da haben also vor dem
impfstoff denke hier ist wirklich
einfach eine unsicherheit da weil das
jetzt was neues ist und dann natürlich
auch über impfpflicht und ähnliches
geredet wird aber ich glaube ich ihm
mehr menschen geimpft werden in
deutschland je mehr auch im umfeld
vielleicht indem
doch bekommen haben und gemerkt haben da
ist überhaupt nichts passiert das ganz
normal ist nichts schlimmes desto
weniger werden die leute angst davor
haben
wenn wir das schaffen würden das wird ja
immer wieder gesagt so bis sommer herbst
eine großflächige impfkampagne
durchzuführen würde das dann im
zusammenhang auch mit dem sommer sie
haben ja auch immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen das ist ein typischer virus
der auch im sommer nicht mehr so
brandgefährlich auftritt oder in einer
so großen menge auftritt wird es dazu
führen dass wir eine große eindämmung
haben wie uns aber im herbst wieder
erwischt ja also man kann damit rechnen
dass dieses corona virus ich genau so
verhält wie alle anderen coronaviren wir
sehen dann im april mai eine abflachung
also so eine langsame abflachung über
die zeit ruhigen sommermonate und dann
kürzlich ein anstieg oktober november
wenn wir jetzt den sommer nutzen und in
dem sinne sind nutzen dass wir gucken
die hygiene konzepte funktionieren zum
beispiel zum anderen aber auch zum
impfen nutzen besteht die hoffnung dass
wir weniger infektionen haben und wenn
wir infektionen haben dass sie kein fan
verlaufen haben würden sie sich jetzt im
augenblick wir stehen ja hier noch
warten bevor das hier alles eröffnet
wird und geimpft wird würden sie sich
unmittelbar impfen lassen wenn sie es
könnten also ich bin generell ein impfen
ich denke impfen ist das beste was man
eigentlich machen kann weil man nur
seinen eigenen körper trainiert sein
eigenes immunsystem dass es gegen einen
erreger vorgehen kann
das ist keine chemie richtig dabei
sondern ist es einfach nur dass man das
eigene immunsystem stärkt ich habe mir
die daten sehr genau angeguckt ich habe
keine sorge für den impfstoff und ich
warte darauf dass ich mich impfen lassen
kann
leider wird es heute wahrscheinlich noch
nicht der fall sein wie gehen wir den
weg eines von jemandem der sich impfen
lassen will
das geht hier durch eine große halle in
dem kongresszentrum durch strikt jetzt
wird es viele geben die trotz der
hinweise die sie uns gerade gegeben
haben sagen
da warte ich lieber ab da bin ich
unsicher mit der impfung
vielleicht gibt es ja doch nach einem
halben jahr um dreiviertel jahr neue
erkenntnisse es gibt aber umgekehrt auch
die diskussion in deutschland
ob man eine impfpflicht einführt oder
was markus wieder vorgeschlagen hat eine
impfpflicht für bestimmte berufe also
etwa pfleger was halten sie davon
also erstmal finde ich stellt sich die
frage im moment gar nicht ob man eine
impfpflicht einführen sollte oder
privilegien oder grundrechte zurück
erlangen wenn man wie impft wurde da wir
ja wie was vorhin schon gesagt haben gar
nicht wissen ob der impfstoff wirklich
schützt vor der infektion oder nur vor
allem schweren verlauf so dass diese
diskussion ob zb pfleger geimpft werden
sollen damit sie das nicht weiter tragen
eigentlich moment gar nicht geführt
werden sollte zusätzlich muss man sagen
dass im moment sich wirklich die pfleger
und pflegerinnen ja in die bresche
geworfen haben für die deutsche
bevölkerung sie haben ein jahr am stück
gearbeitet und cupid 19 patienten
behandelt wir kennen den personalmangel
in den krankenhäusern wir wissen wie
anstrengend dieser job ist und da dann
auch noch darüber zu reden dass die eine
pflicht haben sollen oder sogar gedroht
wird dass sie ihren beruf verlieren das
finde ich einfach fehl am platz in
diesem moment sie haben ein buch
geschrieben das heißt leben mit dem
virus und das ist nicht unabsichtlich
sondern dass er absichtlich gemeint wir
haben gerade schon gesagt wir werden mit
diesem virus leben müssen was bedeutet
das also als erstes haben wir menschen
ist erst ein einziges mal geschafft
einen virus zu reduzieren
das waren die pocken übrigens mit einer
impfpflicht im kaiserreich hat das schon
begonnen wir versuchen es schon seit
jahrzehnten dass wir die pro jahr
reduzieren der rotary club zum beispiel
tut sich da sehr forum
spenden dafür zu sammeln aber es ist
bisher nicht gelungen gerade so ein
virus wie das corona virus wird extrem
schwer sein zu reduzieren bis hin zu
fast unmöglich in den nächsten
jahrzehnten
daher müssen wir damit rechnen dass es
heimisch wird es wird hier wie alle
anderen coronaviren immer wieder zu
wählen bewegung kommen ist im frühjahr
geht es runter im herbst geht's hoch
eine dauerwelle die immer auf und ab
geht
diese viren passen sich an uns an und
wir passen uns an die viren an so dass
sie am ende weniger gefährlich werden
und auch weniger tätig sind und daher
müssen wir anfangen zu lernen mit diesem
virus zu leben und das wichtige ist dass
wir krankheiten vermeiden aber
infektionszahlen auf null zu drücken das
wird uns nicht gelingt wenn wir jetzt
eine solche veränderung haben bei einem
virus aus südafrika eine mutation oder
auch in großbritannien mit sehr viel
größerer ansteckung dann bringt das
unsere zahlen die infektionszahlen
komplett in die höhe
auf der einen seite auf der anderen
seite zeigt es ja dass dieser virus sich
verändert kann der dann auch tödlicher
werden kann der sehr viel aggressiver
werden müssen wir uns da sorgen machen
also dass viren sich verändern deren
mutieren und auch corona viren mutieren
ist nicht so außergewöhnlich dass
passiert andauernd bei dem neuen corona
virus auf zwei wurden bislang über 4000
mutation beschrieben
es gibt jetzt verschiedene varianten
bildung das bedeutet dass sie so viele
mutationen angesammelt haben dass man
eigentlich sagt dass es eine andere
variante des virus
was meistens passiert wir wissen es
natürlich jetzt für das corona virus
noch nicht dass sie leichter übertragbar
werden dass sie auch länger im körper
bleiben aber damit meistens weniger
tödlich also was häufiger passiert ist
dass sie dann hoch in die nase rutschen
und dann lästigen schnupfen machen aber
dadurch nicht so tödlich mehr sind weil
sie die lunge nicht mehr so stark
befallen
andersrum wäre es wenn sie in die lunge
gehen würde dann wäre es nicht mehr so
leicht übertragbaren wir wissen dass für
dieses corona virus noch nicht die
mutationen sehen so aus als ob es
leichter übertragbar wäre
aber man kann nicht darauf schließen
dass es in irgendeiner weise gefährdet
wenn wir jetzt den den gang und des
impfens gehen der so das gefühl hat ich
lasse mich jetzt impfen zur sicherheit
aber es könnte ja mutationen geben kann
es dann auch mutationen geben wo der
impfstoff gar nicht mehr drin das kann
natürlich passieren und gerade natürlich
in personen die geimpft wurden und sich
gleichzeitig infiziert haben
dadurch entsteht ein selektionsdruck
also dem das ist ja evolution in der
making was wir gerade haben weil der
körper baut eindruck durch das
immunsystem auf alle viren auf will
verhindern dass sie sich weiter
vermehren und das virus versucht zu
entkommen und verändert sich und gerade
in menschen die geimpft werden kann es
passieren dass solche viren entstehen
das heißt aber es gibt eine ständige
veränderung wir können nie sagen dieser
virus ist jetzt so wie er ist und wir
haben eine ständige veränderung was aber
dann auch immer bedeutet wenn ein
impfstoff existiert muss man ihn
vielleicht ja auch anpassen
ich finde das selber total fasziniert ja
danach aber man muss sich das so
vorstellen dass jeder infizierte mensch
mit seinem immunsystem von allen seiten
die viren attackiert und das virus
versucht in diesen menschen zu überleben
so gut es geht uns verändert sich es
mutiert natürlich immer entstehen neue
generationen davon die mutiert sind und
da kann es dann mal passieren dass
solche mutationen sich durch drucken und
solche mutationen auf dem nächsten
infizierten menschen weitergegeben
werden
das gute an den impfstoffen es wird
müssen dann nicht wieder bei null
anfangen sondern wir können diese
veränderungen einbauen
man kann auch solche im mosaik im stoffe
zum beispiel machen wo man ganz viele
mutationen schon mit einbaut und auch
gegen die mutation und gegen die
varianten m
aber wir müssen uns darauf einstellen
dass eben
irgendwo in der welt wo es ja gar nicht
in deutschland seien mutation oder
varianten entstehen wo der impfstoff
nicht mehr wirkt oder nur schlecht
wirken wenn wir jetzt mal nicht nur auf
die impfung schauen diese große hoffnung
die wir im augenblick haben sondern wir
gucken auch mal auf die anderen
maßnahmen muss man sagen
eigentlich hat das mit der organisation
nicht so wirklich toll geklappt wenn ich
mich erinnere an den januar wenn ich
mich an rinder an die ersten
diskussionen über masken über die frage
des abstands über die frage wie ist das
mit leuten die aus dem ausland einreisen
müssen wir die eigentlich testen oder
nicht da gibt es einen
kabinettsbeschluss von 13 ersten da
werden noch mal neue kriterien für
einreisen festgelegt ist der virus nicht
viel viel schneller als wir also in der
tat ist das virus extrem schnell ist
verbreitet sich sehr gut und wir müssen
auch mit bei den neuen varianten damit
rechnen dass es viel schneller ist als
wir es uns im moment liebe es man darf
auch nicht den fehler machen dass man
glaubt dass man deutschland alleine
sehen kann in deutschland alleine
eindämmen kann
bei uns entstehen gar nicht unbedingt
die varianten sondern es passiert in
indien brasilien amerika wo eigentlich
gar kein alk eine eindämmung passiert
also auch wenn wir kurzfristig schaffen
eine variante fernzuhalten
wir werden es vielleicht oder
wahrscheinlich gar nicht schaffen diese
variante dauerhaft aus deutschland
heraus zu halten sie arbeiten schon so
lange an dem aids-virus können sie
verstehen warum wir wie kai aus der
kiste gekommen sind als diese dieser
virus sich verbreitete und zu einer
pandemie wurde
warum offenbar unsere gesellschaft nicht
nur sondern für andere und vor allen
dingen auch unsere administration
bürokratie völlig überfordert war und es
im augenblick ja auch noch ist also das
problem mit pandemien es sie passieren
ganz plötzlich und genau dann wenn man
nicht mitrechnet und keiner von uns hat
ja damit gerechnet dass es jetzt
losgehen würde mit einer neuen pandemie
natürlich haben biologen
und epidemiologen gesagt wir müssen uns
besser darauf vorbereiten aber das haben
wir natürlich nicht gemacht
die erst viele nicht wissen hat ein sehr
kleines budget im grunde dafür was sie
für uns ist das budget ist ungefähr so
groß wie das der charité und kann gar
nicht so gut darauf vorbereitet sein und
auch für alle länder da sein um so einer
pandemie herr zu werden
ich glaube das wichtige ist dass wir
jetzt aus dieser pandemie lernen jetzt
wo das wissen noch so gut ist weil die
nächste pandemie steht irgendwann wieder
vor der tür und mit dem wissen was wir
jetzt erlernt haben als weltgemeinschaft
mit dem können wir auch die nächste
pandemie sehr viel besser begegnen sie
gehören ja zu denen die gesagt haben wir
müssen und wir haben gerade im begriff
angst schon besprochen
wir müssen ruhig und seriös und
pragmatisch damit umgehen wir müssen
emotionen runterfahren wir müssen uns
überlegen was ist der sinnvollste weg
dieses virus oder die verbreitung
einzudämmen was hat sie denn am meisten
geärgert an der an dem umgang mit dieser
pandemie bei den verantwortlichen wir
hatten ja sogar diskussionen darüber ob
das nicht zu einem politischen zankapfel
ständig wird also was ist schwierig
finde ist wenn man emotional diskutiert
dabei ist etwas was wir objektiv
betrachten müssen es ist etwas was wir
nicht über die emotionale schiene
argumentieren dürfen wir können gerade
wenn wir uns solche zahlen anschauen
über longo wird aber auch
sterblichkeitsrate das sind objektive
sichtweisen wenn man dann argumentiert
zum beispiel das stürzt jedes jahr jeden
tag ein jumbo-jet
das ist ein sehr emotionales argument da
kann man ja gar nichts gegen sagen jeder
tod ist tragisch jenen todt will man ja
verhindern
aber trotz allem gehört das ja zum bild
einer pandemie
und wir müssen auch jetzt in unserer
argumentation viel besser objektiv auf
die zahlen schauen und das in relation
setzen was es eigentlich bedeutet und
die emotionen
für moment außen vor lassen und das
fehlt das fehlt sie kritisieren ja auch
diese reine orientierung an den zahlen
das haben sie eigentlich von anfang an
gemacht haben gesagt die zahlen sind
relativ weil wir am anfang wenig
getestet haben jetzt hätten wir sehr
viel
es gibt aber auch viele ich sag mal
schwarze löcher in dieser pandemie
nämlich etwa die frage wie eine solche
ansteckung wirklich vonstatten geht es
gibt menschen die sich anstecken die
überhaupt nicht wissen wie das passiert
sein könnte
umgekehrt sagt man ja mit der bahn kann
man fahren dann abstand und maske das
muss funktionieren aber so genau weiß
wann es nicht beim flugzeug ist es
ähnlich die fluggesellschaften sagen aus
eigennutz natürlich auch das ist alles
überhaupt kein problem bei uns eine
tolle klimaanlagen kommen wir da nicht
mal endlich einen schritt weiter und
können wirklich mal sagen wo die
ansteckung und unter welchen bedingungen
funktioniert das sehe ich wirklich als
ein großes problem gerade und auch etwas
was wir versäumt haben
es besteht ein enormes unwissen wie sich
das infektionsgeschehen verhält wer
infiziert sich denn eigentlich wo noch
die sie das eben schon gesagt haben gibt
es bestimmte bereiche büros fabriken
schulen wo sich leute gehäuft infizieren
oder bestimmte berufe polizisten
büroangestellter im großraumbüro etwa da
wird immer noch gearbeitet aber dass das
ist ja eine frage die ihnen zum beispiel
das gesundheitsamt jeden infizierten
stellen kann welchen beruf haben sie
eigentlich wenn man dann sehen würde es
gibt eine gehäufte infektion unter
büroangestellten könnte man spezifischer
vorgehen anstatt wieder mit hammer drauf
zu hauen sondern spezifischer vorgehen
wir haben ein problem in den büros da
stecken sich die menschen an
wir müssen hier entweder um officer
verordnen oder aber masten breiteren
abständen filteranlagen je nachdem
virologen haben jetzt immer an einem
tisch gesessen und die mediziner und
alle anderen wissenschaftler und haben
auf der anderen seite der politik
erklärt was sie eigentlich tun muss das
hat mich immer funktioniert manchmal
ging das völlig daneben
das ist ein bereich in dem auch sie
nicht immer
nicht immer schöne und positive
erfahrungen gemacht haben über die würde
ich mit ihnen gerne noch mal sprechen
wir kommen jetzt hier in den bereich wo
die im kabinen sind wo geimpft wird
nun haben sie gesagt ja impfung das ist
ein teil unserer hoffnung aber es gibt
ja schließlich auch normalerweise
medikamente in ihrer aids forschung
spielen diese medikamente die
entscheidende rolle
warum haben wir noch kein medikament
medikamentenentwicklungen gegen
respiratorische viren wassen corona
virus ist schwierig weil da auch ein
zusammenspiel zwischen immunsystem und
virus ist was noch nicht so ganz geklärt
ist weil da auch das immunsystem
manchmal zu stark reagiert wir kommen
aber schrittweise weiter also wir haben
ja einige ideen wie man therapieren kann
es gibt aber auch andere medikamente die
jetzt entwickelt werden oder auch
vielleicht wirken können ein großes
könnte damals noch nicht weiß eva mac
team das eigentlich milden mittel ist
hat in einigen versuchen ergebnisse
gezeigt ob es dann wirklich funktioniert
da braucht man dann weitere studien
wieder
wir haben ja gerade darüber gesprochen
dass da durchaus kritik von ihnen von
anfang an gekommen ist an den massnahmen
mann hatte vor allen dingen den eindruck
und das haben sie häufiger geäußert die
maßnahmen sind nicht koordiniert und sie
selber sind als virologe ja offenbar
auch immer wieder so ein bisschen in die
welt zwischen politik und ihrer eigenen
verantwortung gekommen
was hat sie am meisten geärgert hat das
ist eine schwierige frage weil es sogar
dann gab es natürlich verschiedene
phasen dabei eine unterschiedliche
bereiche geärgert haben also ein bereich
der mich aber sehr geärgert hatte war
dass man versucht hat an meiner
reputation zu graben absichtlich damit
das was ich sage eben nicht mehr so ein
gewicht hat das ging ja dann sogar so
weit dass ich anzeige bei der dfg
bei der ärztekammer bei der
staatskanzlei oder staatsanwaltschaft
gehabt habe
das ja alles abgewiesen wurde aber dass
das zeigte dass es da gar nicht um die
wissenschaft geht sondern dass meine
meinung einigen menschen nicht gepasst
hat und da sind sie in den strudel
hineingeraten über die persönlichen
konsequenzen und die reaktion würde ich
gerne mit ihnen noch sprechen strickt
sie kommen aus einer akademikerfamilie
aus einer familie von wissenschaftlern
vater und mutter sind psychiater wie
viel ehrgeiz entwickelt man da auch in
der wissenschaft erfolgreich zu sein
ja ich glaube gar nicht dass das so über
die familie gekommen ist bei
ursprünglich wollte ich ja komponist
werden also sie wollten sogar filmmusik
komponiert habe ich ja auch gemacht für
den bayerischen rundfunk damals kleine
projekte aber da war da gar nicht dieser
anspruch gut in der wissenschaft oder
medizin zu sein
ich glaube der den ehrgeiz hat mich
gepackt beim studium ich fand es
unheimlich spannend vor allem auch die
dermatologie die ja wo sich ja auch
schon um infektionen und immunantworten
handelt und meine ersten gehversuche in
diesem bereich habe ich haben robert
koch institut gemacht so dass ich da
sehr schnell eigentlich ja blut geleckt
habe und das einfach spannend fand und
ich glaube wenn man etwas spannend
findet dann hat man auch ehrgeiz noch
mehr rauszuholen die wahl in südafrika
sie haben auch schlimme dinge erlebt in
südafrika viele menschen mit
schusswunden die sie behandelt haben
trotzdem muss man ja eine art von
fokussierung haben sagen da will ich mal
hin dass genau will ich machen war das
immer die virologie wie ist das gekommen
nein das sich in die virologie gegangen
bin ist eigentlich zufall gewesen also
ich hab das schon irgendwann geplant
aber ursprünglich war mein plan er so in
die dermatologie zu gehen
südafrika hat mich in dem sinne geprägt
dass
ich dann im größten krankenhaus in der
südlichen hemisphäre gearbeitet habe dem
chris hani paravan krankenhaus und dort
in der notaufnahme und hier manchmal
überlaufen waren von menschen die
einfach chirurgisch versorgt werden
müssen die geblutet haben über all die
die schwere autounfälle gehabt haben da
hatte ich das gefühl man muss eigentlich
als globaler machen man muss den ganzen
menschen irgendwie helfen und dachte man
muss eben in diesem bereich der
impfstoffforschung gehen bei dort waren
bis zu 70 prozent der bevölkerung hiv
positiv in den soweto hieß die größte
townships von südafrika
dann war ich aber in den usa und habe da
meine doktorarbeit gemacht und dann auch
meinen post doc und das hat mich dann in
die virologie aber wenn sie so
wissenschaftlich geprägt sind ärgert es
sie nicht dass gerade in der diskussion
um diese pandemie der wissenschaft immer
nur dieser kleiner ratschlag bach sagt
uns mal was wir machen sollen
verliehen wird umgekehrt aber immer dann
wenn es um die konkreten anweisungen
geht die die politik dann weitergeben
muss auch gesetzliche plötzlich die
virologen dann nur noch so eine kleine
neben funktion haben da wird dann eher
politisch agiert und reagiert was ich
schade finde ist das von der
wissenschaft manchmal so eine
absolutheit verlangt wird also eine
absolute antwort ist es so oder so oder
ist es nicht man kann sich so nicht
anstecken
das können wir eigentlich gar nicht
leisten diese antworten können wir nicht
geben
im gesamt aspekt dieser diskussion um
die pandemie fehlt mir die
interdisziplinarität ich als virologe ab
meinem fachbereich wo ich gut mit aber
mir fehlt hier die diskussion der
psychologen der soziologen vielleicht
verfassungsrichter wirtschaftsexperte
solchen sachen die politik überfordert
ich denke die bundespolitik der würde es
gut tun wenn sie einen bereiten
expertenrat aufstehen erstellen würde
ähnlich wie das in nrw gewesen ist aber
vielleicht noch viel breiter noch viel
mehr verschiedene expertise viel mehr
verschiedene stimmen weil auch physiker
kennen ihren
da ich aber soziologen zum beispiel
können die menschen viel besser
einschätzen werden wir denn vielleicht
auch in der bevölkerung am ende der
pandemie nicht am ende des virus wie wir
erfahren haben ein großes verständnis
dafür haben dass wissenschaft des kochs
bedeutet dass wissenschaft bedeutet
heute eine erkenntnis die man
möglicherweise morgen falsifiziert wo
man sagt das stimmt jetzt doch nicht wir
müssen noch mal weitermachen
ich würde mir das wünschen dass wir auch
jetzt in der pandemie und auch heute
schon anfangen würden viel mehr
diskutieren team er auch einen
öffentlichen diskurs führen
meine kollegen in der virologie wir sind
sonst eigentlich in nuancen
unterschiedlich in unserer meinung es
wird aufgebauscht auch als ein großer
streit aber auch der präsident der
gesellschaft für virologie und ich wir
telefonieren miteinander wir verstehen
uns da ist kein streit da ist ein
diskurs und den kann man vielleicht auch
besser darstellen und das würde
vielleicht auch vielen bürgern
interessieren zu sehen dass auch
virologen miteinander ganz normal
diskutieren sie machen gerne sport wenn
auch im augenblick wenig weil sie viele
termine haben wird das wirklich ein
marathonlauf diese pandemie zu besiegen
eine pandemie ist eigentlich immer ein
marathonlauf wenn wir jetzt noch mal an
hiv denken 1981 hatten wir die ersten
aids patienten in den usa die
beschrieben wurden wir laufen diesen
marathon immer noch und wir können
mittlerweile ein normales leben für
einen hiv-positiven ermöglichen der
einen anderen menschen nicht mehr
anstecken kann und die gleiche
lebenserwartung hat aber medikamente
nehmen muss und genau so müssen wir
diese pandemie begreifen auch wenn wir
nicht die finale lösung für das virus
hatten das virus nicht eher reduzieren
können können wir ein normales leben
ermöglichen und darum geht es am ende ja
dann hoffen wir dass der marathonlauf
vielleicht dann doch nicht über die
volle distanz geht danke hinrich strikt
dass sie waren dankeschön
vielen dank